the examples of this sort of anti trade
sentiment that are coming out of Denver
in the last couple of nights are the
consistent constant in idiotic
references to people's jobs being
shipped overseas and the the need to
protect American jobs in the key word
there is protect because of course this
is like you know not even very coded a
protectionist language and that that's
obviously bad for the American economy
but but it makes good politics
especially when you don't want to bring
up the immigration issue so here's the
one line that as a libertarian freaked
me out was Joe Biden promising that
Obama would transform our economy that
kind of language and it was the same
thing with the Clinton speech to
Clinton's taking credit for the great
economy of the 90s it's like we really
need to keep in mind the president
whoever is the President does not have
that much to do with how good the
economy is it is basically irrelevant
and to promise that Obama will transform
our economy is horrifying there's
obviously no specific libertarian issues
being addressed cuz no specific issues
being addressed in general but I would
say that that that that word is should
be frightening to libertarians is
transformation of XY and Z which usually
implies whether a democrat or republican
is saying it is some sort of massive
government intervention into people's
lives are into the economy Michelle
Obama had previously said that that
Barack Obama will call Americans into
service in that was reiterated last
night and I think that that is a
frightening prospect for most people and
it sounds a bit new delish and a bit CCC
ish to to most people Hillary Clinton
last night I thought was a little scary
on the question of foreign laborers
demonizing the Chinese talking about
jobs being shipped overseas you know the
last thing if America isn't in some sort
of economic downturn
which i think is a disputable assertion
but even if that's the case the last
thing we need to do and the end the
lesson new deal with the smoot-hawley
tariff is pretty strong on this is last
thing we need to do is build a roll-up
protectionists wall around the country
and keep out and in restrict trade and
restrict the ability of americans and
and foreign businesses and individuals
to trade with each other so the idea
that the democrats are going to restrict
red are going to put up trade barriers
bill clinton talk tonight about a war on
unions i'm making sure what he's
referring to there but presumably he'd
like to strengthen position of american
labor by keeping out foreign labor
immigration something that Democrats
haven't talked about at all the labor
unions are obviously not for letting
mexicans and foreign laborers in as a
surrogate for talking about immigration
they're talking about red that's another
that's like they're like dual fears that
you can you can hit people like or they
think hit people in the heartland with
and that is i would say that on the
libertarian point that is one of the
more horrifying sort of themes through
the last three nights is that free trade
of some sort of evil and that we have to
protect American jobs how we do that is
presumably by by putting up walls a
trade